-Welcome, welcome, welcome!
You look awesome, buddy.
Thank you so much
for coming back to the show.
-Thank you.
-This is not our normal studio
where we normally
interview each other.
This place, this is Studio 6A.
It's smaller.
But we once played here
together, too.
And I'm sure, of course,
you remember this.
[ Laughter ]
Alright.
I'll refresh your memory.
[ Laughter ]
Let me tell you this.
-Give me a hint.
-So this is where Conan O'Brien
used to do his show.
-Ah!
-So we were here one time.
I was a guest on the show
with Conan.
And you came on with
The Sessions Band, wasn't it?
-Right. Right.
-So I was there.
I was so excited to see you
and everything.
And I got a knock on my door,
on my dressing room door.
And it was you and Patti
and you go like,
"Hey, Jimmy."
Pardon the impression.
[ Laughter ]
-That doesn't sound like me.
-No, no, no, no, no, no!
[ Laughter ]
So you go, "Dude, do you know
how to play the spoons?"
And I go, "What?
Hi, first of all. Hi.
Oh, yeah, sure. I'll do it."
And you go,
"Well, come on, play the spoons
with the band for this song."
I go, "Okay, okay,
I'll play the spoons."
So you're like,
"Yeah, let's get the spoons!"
I go,
"Yeah, I'll get the spoons!"
You go, "Spoons!"
And I go, "Yeah, spoons!"
I don't even know where
am I going to find spoons.
I ran down to the commissary --
true story -- and I go,
"You guys got to give me
two spoons
'cause Bruce just asked me
to play with him in the band
and I got to do it,"
and I couldn't even believe it.
You asked me to do it.
I was so excited.
And I think we have a clip.
Here I am playing the spoons
with Bruce Springsteen.
Take a look at this.
♪♪
I could see it all
coming back to you.
-Well, I like that you broke
a sweat in about five seconds.
[ Laughter ]
-I was that excited.
-That's how easy it was.
-I'm the first person to break
a sweat playing spoons.
-That's right.
-Why spoons?
It just fit the sound?
-That's the only band
that you could play spoons in,
I believe, and make it sound --
Or you can also --
the washboard.
We've had people come out of
the audience for that band --
when they come, they come
dressed in their own washboard.
-Bring your own washboard.
-Next time we'll get you
the washboard.
-I'll always have one
in the dressing room
just in case you ask me.
Congrats on "Letter to You."
The record is --
well, it's a beautiful --
it's a beautiful inspiration
to why you wrote this record.
But talk to me about it.
How do you get into this?
-I always like music
that was where the singer
sounded happy
and sad simultaneously,
you know, and I wrote
about this a little bit
in the memoir that I wrote,
where I always love
The Drifters'
"Saturday Night at the Movies,"
"Up on the Roof,"
"Under the Boardwalk."
For some reason, the singer
always sounded
hopeful, resigned.
Like he had his spirit,
but sad at the same time,
and you felt the whole world
open up to you.
So those are the kind of songs
that I like, you know,
and that I think
hit the deepest.
If you're lucky enough
to be able to write one
or a small group of them,
and "Letter to You" kind of
strikes that balance.
And it's a record
I'm really proud of.
I'm proud of the writing
and the playing on it.
-It's about people
that you have lost,
as well that you've played with,
but also people that you haven't
really played with yet.
-Right.
-But also, I think
"Letter to You" --
I mean, obviously,
people take their own meaning
from a song.
But right now, in these times
it was speaking to me,
whereas it could be
speaking to you.
-Yeah, a little.
You know, its...
Well, its original inspiration
was I had a close friend of mine
who was in my very first band,
and he passed away a couple
of years ago in the summertime.
I went down and saw him
before he died.
And I came back
and I -- it was just,
you know, it just sat with me,
and that's --
and the song called
"Last Man Standing."
I ended up being
the last living member
of the first band
that I was ever in.
And there's something about
I was in a band
that lasted for three years
with teenagers.
I mean, that's very,
very unusual.
-Right, yeah.
-From 1965 to '68,
from when I was 15 to when I was
18, it was the same guys,
the same guys from high school
in the same band.
And so -- and it was
my entire school of rock.
Every basic lesson
that I learned,
I learned in that band --
the beginnings of performing,
how to put a show together,
the beginnings of your writing,
everything.
Everything began
during those three years
with that band,
so that's something that --
and it was a momentous time
in American history.
1965 to '68, you know,
it was just tumultuous.
And so it was a very,
very memorable part of my life.
And so I started to write
a little -- some of the songs
were set a little bit
in that time period
where I went back a little bit
and thought about what it was
like to play in the Elks Club,
the Firemen's Fair,
the Union Hall,
in front of the drive-in movies,
before the movie stars,
the VFW hall, and all those
sort of very definitive
but small gigs that you play
when you're just learning
your chops and your way,
you know.
So the record sort of stretches
from that time period
all the way to now.
Whereas the modern record that
I cut with the E Street Band,
who I've been working with
for 45 years or so,
and it's about --
part of it's about a life,
a life in music, you know,
and it's about the music itself
and the role it plays
in people's lives,
the role that it's played
in my life.
And it's a bit summational
as a record like that, you know?
-Do you remember --
When you were 15,
do you remember the first taste
you got of, like, getting on
a stage or performing in front
of a crowd or that vibe?
-It was at the Elks Club
in Freehold,
and I went in about a month ago
just to see
if the room was still there
that I first played in.
And they redesigned
the inside of it.
So it wasn't recognizable
at this point.
But they had a nice
little bar downstairs and...
[ Laughter ]
-Did you hop on stage
with the band?
-No, it was 35 cents.
You played on Sunday,
35 cents to get in.
There was a room about this size
and there was a circle of --
the bands would set up
in a circle,
and every band would play
about three songs
then the next band would play
three or four or five songs
and the next band would play
for a little bit.
And all the bands
were playing for free, you know.
And, you know,
maybe there was...
It was less than 100 kids there,
but it was an amazing place
to kind of start out.
And I remember -- the only thing
I remember most is I got up
and I sang "Twist and Shout,"
and I've been singing it
ever since.
-Was that your first song
you learned?
-That was the first rock song.
You know, the first song
I ever learned
was a song called
"Greensleeves."
[ Crowd murmuring ]
[ Laughter ]
You can hear the reaction
from your audience.
[ Laughter ]
-"You guys will hear
'Greensleeves'!
"Please play 'Green--'" Wow!
-Playing "Greensleeves"?!
[ Laughter ]
Damn!
-Wow!
We thought that was going to
come with the encore.
You're gonna open with
"Greensleeves"?
-It was a folk song.
The first thing I had was
a big American --
a big book of
American folk music.
And so I learned that first
because it only had two chords.
And then eventually I made
my way to the third chord,
which allowed you to play
"Twist and Shout," so...
-Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
-And then the documentary,
by the way,
I'm so happy that you did it.
Did you think for a second
that you weren't
going to do a documentary
or did you know
that you would film this?
-Well, I regretted not filming
the band when we were young
because I was superstitious.
And I believed that the magician
should not look
too closely
at his magic trick, you know?
And so I didn't
want to really --
I didn't want to see the band.
Everything was going so well.
I said it can only screw
everything up.
So we didn't film a lot
when we were younger.
So as we've gotten a little bit
older now,
I try to film mostly
everything we do.
We get some sort of footage on,
and the documentary
for this record
came up just like that.
I just have
a filmmaking partner.
Thom Zimny is the director.
I said, "Thom, just come down
and film what happens,
you know, just come down
and shoot what happens."
And then we start there.
We start with
just the basic --
started with just the band
learning the songs
and then playing the songs
and then listening to the songs.
And then
we sort of add tone pieces,
which were sort of me
just meandering.
[ Laughs ]
-No, no, it's not mean--
-I meander through the film.
-You meandering is --
-40 minutes.
-No, it's beautiful, trust me.
-But that's how we put it
together.
-Do you think that you changed
your delivery of your stories
or the structure of your stories
from doing all of your Broadway?
-Well, you know, the thing
about Broadway was it was --
it really got me
deep into the storytelling.
You know, it was really a --
Most of the night
was really spoken word
and, you know, and then I'd play
a play a song for a little bit
and then speak again, so...
It got me -- That particular
show sort of got me thinking
about the whole arc of my life
from when I was a kid to now,
and the series of projects
started with me
writing a memoir
and a Broadway show,
and then to some degree,
the music that's come
after it also, you know,
has been a part of just taking
a look at where I've been,
what I've done,
where I'm at now, you know?
-When you get all
the guys together in the room,
you can kind of feel like
it's an old gang.
-Well, it is an old gang.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't mean that.
-It's a very old gang.
-No, no, no.
I don't mean like old.
I mean like old buddies, yeah.
-But it is, you know.
I mean, I've been with Steve
and Garry and all the guys,
you know,
since I was -- once again,
since I was 18,
19, 20, 21 years old.
-Are you the same
or I mean, as far as the band,
like, do you have
the same dynamics?
Because now
and then Max will go like,
"Hey, do you want like --
I think you should do this."
Were you always like that?
-I would say
you do have the same dynamics.
I mean, you do sort of play
the same roles
with some interesting bits.
Steven assisting me arrange
something from 30 years ago
and then him doing
the exact same thing,
you know, six months ago,
you know?
So your relationships,
they're very unusual.
Rock 'n' roll music
is the only job in the world
where imagine this -- the people
you went to high school with,
the very same people
50 years later,
you're working
with those same people.
[ Laughter ]
Those exact same people,
and you've been with them
every day since.
[ Laughter ]
So there is no other job
in the world where that occurs.
It only occurs
in a rock 'n roll band,
and it's only even expected
to work out there.
It's no surprise
that most bands break up.
I mean, how could you not,
really, you know?
-Yeah, it's almost like
a social experiment.
"Let's see who snaps first."
-Somebody should figure us out
because we've been
pretty lucky with it.
And I have had great guys,
and we've kind of prioritized
the life and spirit of the band
above some of
our own personal grudges
and our own things
that we got against this guy
and he's got against you,
you know.
All those things are there,
but we've managed to transcend
them in a lovely way
at this point in time.
-I want to show everyone a clip
from the documentary.
Here is Bruce Springsteen
in "Letter to You."
Take a look at this.
♪♪
-The E Street Band
makes me dream,
think, and write big.
When I am amongst my friends,
I allow a certain part
of my mind
that seems to be reserved
for only them,
to be set free, and I dwell
in a house of a thousand dreams.
-More with Bruce Springsteen
when we come back, everybody!